>> Dave: THE TAMPA BAY
LIGHTNING DO NOT
BOTH TEAMS ARE GOING BACK AND
FORTH IN THE OPENING TWO AND IN
NET WATCH THE LIGHTNING COME IN
OUT OF THE ZONE.
THEY TRAP FRFR
AND BOUNCINGON THE
EDGE OF THE CREASE.
THE LIGHTNING LEAVE IT THERE.
EVERYBODY GOES FOR A
0-1 TONIGHT.IN THE NHL IN
THAT SHORT SEASON.
YOU HAHAMAN CAUGHT.
THEY THE OUTSIDE OF THE
POST.
GOSTISBEHERE DROPS IT OFTEN
HERE COMES --
IT IS MAYO WHO MISHANDLED THE
PUCK.
I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING
HE IS INJURED RIGHT NOW.
>> Dave: STEVEN STAMKOS HAS
THE REBOUND IS PICKED UP BY
HE EARNED HIS WAY ONTO THE
TEAM.
THEY HAVE HAD SOME THE CHANGES.
10 TRAITS IN 19VERY END.
McDONOUGH TRY TO GET IT ACROSS.
SENT BACK IN AND STROMAN BACK
TO VED BY VASILEVSKIY.
HE HAS BEEN TRACKING THE PUCK.
STAMKOS ACROSS
THIRD PERIOD.
MIDDLE OF THE PLAY THEY HAVE
SEEN SOMETHING AND IT MUST'VE
GONE IN.
BOSTON CRCR
YOU TALK ABOUT DETAILS, HE IS A
OVERTIME.
A BIG SMILE FOR
HE COMES OUT AN
MAKES THE SALE.
HE SCORED THAT.